- Hello, thank you for joining us today,
we know how busy you are as
parents of young children
particularly during these times
with so much going on in the world.
We wanna make the session
a really valuable use
of your time, so we're
gonna jump right in.
I'm Caroline Huflexor and
I'm the CEO and co-founder
of Khan Academy Kids,
and today I am joined
by my colleague Dan Tu,
who will be moderating
our questions later.
And our special guest Renee Scott.
Renee is a longtime early educator
and is early education program director
at Stanford University.
She's been one of our
main curriculum advisors
as we've developed Khan Kids.
And Renee and I are both parents
and we will be talking about
how to keep young kids engaged
and learning at home while
many schools are closed,
and families are going through
a lot of transition this fall.
We're nonprofit, and I'd
like to thank our sponsors,
Bank of America, AT&T,
google.org, Novartis and Fastly
for their support of this webinar
and our other distance learning resources.
A few other notes, this
webinar will be recorded.
And we'll be sending a copy to
you via email in a few hours.
And if you have questions,
please enter them in the question box.
We'll save time at the
end for live Q and A.
So, today we'll be focusing mostly
on the youngest children
ages two through seven.
So, preschool through grade one.
Let's get started.
I am thrilled to have
Renee with us here today.
Can you share a little bit about yourself
and your background?
- Sure.
Thanks, Caroline.
I am a lifelong teacher.
I started long ago as a swim instructor
when I was in high school and just kept on
that teaching path.
So now I've taught kindergarten,
first grade, fourth grade,
sixth grade, and I'm
currently teaching teachers
how to engage in engage young children
with reading and math,
specifically in pre-k and
kindergarten and first grade.
And as you mentioned, I'm also a mom,
my kids are now a teen and preteen.
So I've seen a lot of stages with them.
- Wonderful, thanks Renee.
Some parents of young children
are typically the ones
who are the really stressed
then, even in the best of times.
And right now, in this pandemic,
they're juggling even more so
on top of work and childcare,
their heightened health and
financial and medical concerns.
And now with school closures,
a lot of parents are managing
the distance learning
for their young children.
What's your big message to parents
as they are getting through these times
and wanna keep their children
learning and developing?
- So you're exactly right.
It is a stressful time right now
trying to figure out how to
juggle things in a new way.
And really, I think my big message is
to all of you parents out there,
you're already doing a lot.
Give yourself some grace and
give your kids some grace too.
It's a lot to take on
and here's the thing,
kids are learning all the time,
whether you're teaching them something,
or you're just hanging out
with them doing something.
So, there's a pretty good chance that
some of those things that
you're engaged in, for example,
your bedtime routine,
that's engaging in learning.
They're learning about time.
They're learning about
how to reflect on the day,
they're using language.
So today, we're gonna spend some time
talking a little bit about
what that might look like
and how to insert some
intentional language
into how to support your development.
- That's great.
Yeah, can you give me some examples of
some of these everyday activities
and how you could use language
as you go through the second.
- Definitely.
So, one of the things that
I like to remind myself of
is that when you go to
a preschool classroom,
a lot of times you'll notice that kids
are working in some sort of center
and they're working with others.
And there we call them
sort of workplace centers
maybe they're working on a painting
or they're working on listening to books
with a friend or through a tape recorder.
And so I like to think about
working with young children
even at home in these ways
to think about how to organize your day.
So for example,
just looking for opportunities
perhaps to use your language
and language development and
ask really good questions,
and just being intentionally
during an activity
such as bath time,
it's really a great time to talk about
maybe sensory skills and
fine motor asking kids, hey,
I wonder how do these bubbles feel?
How do they feel to you,
you can introduce words
like fluffy, wet, slippery,
those are really great words to practice
and it builds out their vocabulary.
Bath times also really great
time to make up stories
and making up stories
is brilliant for kids.
It helps prep them for learning to read,
for learning to write,
for starting to understand
things like history
and social studies.
So, it's one of those activities
that's really fun when they're little,
that just has a ton of
payoff and benefits.
So if your kids to hop into the bath,
and they've got a fish
in a frog and just, say,
some really great questions
to ask, or, oh, what happens,
tell me a story about fish and frog,
and then keep the conversation going.
So what happens next,
and then what happens?
And tell me more about that.
So, if you can just keep
your kids talking about
something like that,
and perhaps use some of
that more difficult language
they don't know yet and encourage them
to use that in their speech.
It works great.
Another great example of something
that you're gonna have to do
anyway, is brushing teeth.
I know it can be a challenge,
but it's also a great time
maybe to practice math.
You can set a timer
that the kids can watch,
they can count the timer down backwards.
They keep track of each other
counting down backwards,
counting forwards, maybe
they can see how many times
they can hop on a foot before they're done
with their brushing.
It's also I've heard a lot
of kids sing their ABCs
while they wash their hands.
So these are just some really easy,
but intentional ways to include a lot of
the vocabulary language
and math type skills
that are really gonna help them
when they get back into the classroom.
One that we love at my house is baking.
And I think a lot of folks feel like oh,
well, baking is obvious
because it involves
measuring and pouring
and things like that.
But I think it's easy
to forget things like,
can you count how many blueberries
we're gonna put into each of the muffins
and put them into the cups,
sorting things is amazing for kids.
And that's a natural
way to get them sorting
and get them thinking
about dividing and grouping
and to use mathematical terms.
But they're doing it right there
at your kitchen counter, maybe.
And something you have to do,
maybe you're making muffins
for breakfast or your neighbor
to help them out.
So, those are easy ways to include that.
Another one that's great
is get out the recipe
and like kids look at it,
if they can't read it, that's okay.
They can look for words that start with M,
they can look for how many ingredients,
show them where the ingredient list is.
And sometimes they have
numbers in front of them,
have them count out all the ingredients.
Those are just some quick ways to do
to push these things into
what you're already doing.
My daughter and I always
like to sing songs.
The other day,
we had a conversation
she's a little older now
but we still like to
talk about song lyrics.
And we were singing "The Method Man" song.
♪ You know the method man, the method ♪
and I was telling her, I
used to have this little boy
when I taught kindergarten,
who just love that song.
And I said, but I always wondered
about the word drury lane,
I said it's a hard word to say.
And drury sounds kind of dreary.
And so we had this whole
conversation that included
all this language and that's
the kind of silly conversation
that ends up being something that
includes a lot more vocabulary.
So, one more example of
just integrating stuff
into the everyday, one
of the things I love is,
thinking about ways to be
intentional about eating
maybe not always at the dinner table,
but lunch table or breakfast table
is a great time to do this.
Using that time for counting
is a great example of putting
something in there quickly.
So, you're handing out grapes to the kids
and ask them how many
grapes would you like
and have them tell you and
then give them some grapes,
you can mix this up,
you can give them what they asked for
and have them double check
and see if you're right
or you can give them
what they didn't ask for
and have them double check
and see if they catch you.
So, kids really love that
aspect of there's a game in it,
so and you can turn something into a game
and make it playful, is great.
- Great, I love hearing your examples
because it's comforting to hear
that there's so much learning
in terms of language development
and early numeracy that can just come up
in everyday activities and things.
So it's not like (mumbling)
you don't have to sit your child down.
And in fact,
if you just sit your child
down and say, do this,
it's probably not nearly as
fun and engaging for them.
So, I love how you should
always be play base
for young kids,
which is how we approach
the learning in Khan Kids.
So as an educator,
what are some techniques
that teachers used
to keep kids engaged and
learning through the day,
especially as parents, we're
juggling work and multitasking
and can't always be 100% focused on
and playing with our kids all the time.
- Yeah, definitely.
One of the things I mean,
the reality is there's gonna
be periods during the day
when your kid, you can't sit
down and play with your child.
You can't play a game with them.
You maybe can't talk to them.
You're on the phone.
And the first thing again,
I wanna reiterate, that's okay.
Like, it's okay for your
kids to have to hang out
and entertain themselves for a while,
if that's what you need.
Everyone's gonna be happier
if you're feeling better
about what you're doing too.
So give yourself grace there.
But one thing that I do
like to keep in mind,
and you were you kind of alluded to this
just a second ago
Caroline, about motivation
is sometimes the second you
ask a child to do something
that they otherwise might do just for fun.
It's not that fun to them anymore.
It's a matter of trying to convince them
that is their idea, right?
So some of the things that
have been found, actually,
this always makes me think of my mentor,
Deborah Steinbeck because
she does a lot of research
on motivation with young children.
And she really highlighted
a few important things.
And the ones that I wanna
talk about briefly today
are competence, autonomy,
and care and connection.
So, what are those mean, right?
So, competence is just basically kids
like to feel like they
know what they're doing.
So going back to that
great example, if you,
if they're able to catch
you giving them four grapes,
when they asked for five,
they feel really competent.
And also you get to see
that they know what,
they know a skill and then you,
it gives you that indication,
okay, we can check,
we can make this a little
more difficult for them
and kids love the challenge.
So, kind of up the challenge on them if
when you get sense that
they're ready for it,
they think that's exciting.
The other thing is language
around that is important.
So be careful not to always
say good job, good job,
good job, because it's hard
to know what that means.
So I really love the
response of you did it.
Oh my gosh, you figured that out.
You notice that?
So just being really, specific.
Oh, I saw that you put five
blocks all together in a pile.
Wow, how did you put that together.
So, rather than just saying good job,
use it as a chance to
elicit more conversations.
But also let them know that you observed
that they did something
that was kind of cool.
So, then getting back
to those other ideas,
autonomy is just basically
giving them choices.
I don't know if you've ever
heard a pre-k teacher do this,
or if you've received the advice where
you always run the risk of asking
when you just don't give a child a choice,
you say something like,
do you wanna sit down and
color a picture with me,
you run the risk of them saying, nope,
and then you're right.
Love to have choice.
It makes them feel a little
bit more independent.
It gives them some agency.
So, offer a couple of things to them.
If you know you're gonna be on
the phone for a few minutes,
you can say here's three
things that you can do.
What do you wanna start with?
Do you wanna start with the puzzle
or the blocks or the coloring
and let them just pick the thing
and then say when you're done,
you can move to the next
thing that you want to do,
but that way you're giving them
some specific things to do.
So, you're still putting
boundaries around it,
but they get to choose.
And then finally,
the caring connection piece
is really, really important.
It's super hard right now
'cause sometimes you're trying
to listen to a phone call
and you've got your little one going
mommy, mommy, mommy, right?
And it feels like you just wanna,
it's a lot sometimes to
handle all of that at once.
And so, it's important
to maybe set aside time
to make those points of
connection with your child.
One of my favorite things to recommend
and to do is to have a
moment at either at bedtime
or bath time or even first
thing in the morning,
where you ask them a few questions
just to tap into their day.
Our favorite thing at our house is to do
what we call rose, thorn, and bird.
And so with the rose,
you ask them something
great that happened that day
that made them feel beautiful.
A thorn is maybe something that was ouchy
that they didn't like very much
and bird is something that
they're looking forward to.
Some days we just do a bird, my kid Sam,
oh, I'm really looking
forward to this thing,
sometimes we just do an ouchy
because we end up talking
about it for a while.
And it's important to make
sure that your kids feel like
all of how all of these things are okay.
That you're here.
You may not even want it,
you don't wanna offer suggestions
for how to fix it necessarily.
You just want them to
have a chance to tell you
what's going on and kind of
get stuff off their chest,
little kids need to vent too.
So, you're their most
comfortable person to vent to.
So that's important,
because then they know
that they can come to you
when they need it,
but that it's okay for
them to go a little further
during the day and be
independent on their own
when you're not always there.
It helps that safety factor.
So, it's very important.
- Another part is that
maintaining routines
is really important for young children.
Why is that and how do you recommend
that parents do that at home?
- Yeah, yeah, good question.
It's really, it can feel really daunting.
And I wanna encourage parents
that you don't feel like
you have to write up
a separate lesson plan for your child
on top of your own plans every day.
But routine at the same
time routines are important.
They help create a
sense of safety for kids
that helps them know that
they're going to be fed
at a certain time and
there's comfort in that,
they know they're being taken
care of and looked after.
It also helps you helps them to know
what your expectations are of them.
So if they know that after dinner,
their job is to always
help clean up the dishes,
there's comfort in that,
they know that that's something
that they're supposed to do
and it helps lower their anxiety levels,
which ultimately helps
with things like meltdowns
because they are aware
of what is coming up
and what their expectations are.
So one thing I wanna encourage you to do
is to make your routine work for you.
In the evening before you go to sleep
or first thing in the
morning when you get up,
take a look at your own schedule.
Figure out when do you,
when are there times
when you can maybe work with
your child on something?
And where are the times
when you really do need
to have alone time and you're gonna have
to maybe put some things
out for your child
to work on their own and
give them those directions,
perfectly fine as well to prompt them,
give them something and say, hey,
I want you to build and when I come back,
I want you to tell me
about what you built.
So, that's a nice way to get it
or maybe not I want you to build
but here's some blocks, do you wanna build
and then let them go with it again,
you want it to be their idea,
but making sure you go back
and make that touch point when
you connect with them again,
and always come back with a smile,
let them know you're happy
to be there with them.
And not add on a lot to them,
but just let them just be with them.
One thing yeah, that we've,
I've been talking to
Caroline about a little bit
is how to set up a schedule for your child
and so I know that something Caroline that
is really exciting right now
on the Khan Academy Kid's programming.
- Yeah, we just launched weekly planners
for ages two through seven.
And it's just the template, a
starting point for families.
We worked with Renee
and one of the most valuable parts of it,
I think are just kind
of all the tips in there
and ideas for how to fill your,
how to build the time for
early literacy and math,
social emotional development.
And it's not that you have
to stick really rigidly
to the planner
but it's just a place where
parents can start with a routine
and some structure.
- And most importantly,
be creative in how you're thinking
remember that you may be using
math or language or literacy
in places that you might not identify.
So, think through what's
happening in your day
and just identify that you
can write that on the planner
as that's our we did it during
teeth brushing this morning
and then you don't have to
feel like that's another check
on your list.
You can make that anything you want.
- Exactly.
Great.
So should we shift now
to some of the questions
from the audience?
I think Dan from our team
is gonna be joining us.
- Yep, thank you, Caroline.
Before we get started
with the live questions
and answer period,
there's couple announcements
that I'd like to make.
So first, as Caroline
mentioned at the start of this,
this entire webinar is being recorded,
so don't worry if you missed anything,
or if you joined late,
the recording will be made available.
We'll be posting it after this session.
And then also excitingly,
as Caroline mentioned,
we did create the weekly planners
and we've actually attached those
as part of this webinar as well.
So in our downloadable
sections, please go there.
There are two things that
we wanna share with you,
the weekly planners for
kids ages two to seven,
and also one cheater quick tip sheet
of some of the topics
that Renee and Caroline
spoke to just now.
And then finally,
before we get started with
the live question and answers,
please start putting your
questions in the question box.
We have a team of moderators
who are kind of surfacing up for me.
I'll do my best job to get
through as many of them possible
as possible with Renee and Caroline.
Okay, so shall we get started?
- Okay.
- So, Caroline perhaps
this one's a good place
to start with you.
We have a great question from Laura.
Laura asked when so much of
the interaction with school
is through an iPad,
how can I help my child
transition on and off,
and so that she can more easily engage
in the actual physical world?
- Yes, I completely
understand that when I mean,
I think it may be a starting point
is what Renee was talking
about what the schedule
is like, understanding,
what's coming from her school,
and what's the schedule
that they're proposing?
How much of that is on an iPad
and then maybe you have some other time PE
or something where it's not a live better,
or maybe the teacher
is actually leading you
through things there.
But something visual is
often helpful for children
so that they can kind of see
okay, I'm here right now.
The next block, I'm gonna
be doing something else.
I have to go find a book
or I have to go find
something else in my house.
And I think maybe giving them
a little advanced warning too,
is you're about to transition
into the next period.
Let's try this.
Khan Kids, we also have some complimentary
offline activities so that
they can use principles
that reinforce the learning
that's in the app too.
So that gets off the screen.
- Those are great ideas, I.
May I add one thing quickly,
just that often in preschools
and kindergarten classrooms,
teachers will use music
during transition times.
So, I'll let you love you
could play it for a minute
while it's time to put one thing away
and take the next thing out.
Sometimes that helps kids know,
'cause it's, it goes
along with the schedule
and it signals oh, we're gonna change.
We're gonna shift gears here.
Let's look at our schedule
and see what's coming up next.
- Great, thank you.
We have a question from Ruth.
The question is I have
a young kindergartener
and a three year old,
and Ruth worries that
when the kindergartner
potentially falling behind
with the social skills
given the distance learning
and our shelter in place rules.
And also she worries that about
potential attachment issues
once the kids have to go back to school.
So Renee, perhaps this
is a good one for you
to kind of address how do we
deal with attachment issues
and the lack of kind
of social interactions
or the limited interactions that we have?
- Right, right.
And I think that's
definitely a great question.
It's something that even
the education community
is trying to think a lot about.
And this is actually one
area where I might recommend
that you try to embrace
technology a little bit more even
to get your kids maybe
communicating with family members,
or if they have friends
that they might be able
to communicate with the
help of another parent.
And the parents can be there with you,
but just to give them that
sense of being able to play,
I've seen kids play games
over like a Facebook type
or a Zoom type situation and they can play
all sorts of games or they
can do jumping jacks together
or something that you that
a parent models for them.
But in that way they can start to interact
and use some language back and forth.
Admittedly, it's not the same
as if they're playing
necessarily next to each other,
but it is helpful.
Another thing I love is,
it's a great time to do some
reflecting with your child.
There's some really wonderful books
about social emotional learning.
And so it might be a good time,
especially in kindergarten,
might be a time when they
can reflect back on time,
experiences that they've had before
that align with what
they're reading in the book.
And so you can say, oh,
have you ever felt like
this at a certain time,
and then you can actually share
your own experience as well.
So, it's definitely a challenge.
But I encourage you to
continue to be creative.
And let your little one
kind of help each other out
if they can, if they're
able to do that too.
- Great.
So the next one is quite a tough one.
I'll let you both answer this.
And Caroline, since probably good for you.
And this is one that we hear a lot.
And I'm sure this resonates
with a lot of our audience.
So Cindy asks, I'm on day four of school
and I'm already getting a
I don't wanna do school,
what is a good way to help them?
Get their kids excited to start the day?
- Yeah, that is a tough
one, especially on day four.
I might start with asking your child,
why are you feeling that way today?
And it could be a whole host of things.
It could be that I don't like sitting here
in front of my computer for so long.
It could be I don't
know who's in my class.
So, I think depending on that answer,
you may have, you may
trigger some ideas for you.
For example, if it is the screen,
like maybe there's conversation
that you could have
with a teacher to see
if there are parts where
he or she does not need to be logged in
and maybe she can do
something else offline, or.
Yeah, I think it's not understanding why,
I don't know, Renee,
do you have other things to
add on this one, it's tough.
- That is a tough one.
That's a great place to start.
It's really understandable
that little ones
might need to move around a
little bit more than they are.
I would also recommend that
you contact the teacher
and explain that that's happening,
not necessarily as a complaint,
but it's a nice way for a teacher to gauge
how things are going.
Our teachers are working
really hard to develop classes
that the kids will be interested in.
But this is their time doing it as well.
And so when you give them feedback,
it lets them know how to that
they might want to adjust
and change for your child.
My other thought is if it's allowed,
maybe let your child
bring a lovey to class,
or something that makes
them feel comfortable
depending on the age of the child.
And if that's okay with the teacher,
that might be a way to
help with that as well.
Or perhaps you could sit with them
for some of the class time.
Maybe not all of it,
but some of it just until they transition
and start to feel better.
But I agreed, Caroline,
I think you have the right approach
in terms of just trying to figure out
what it might be that's
creating that pushback.
- Well, I'd like to say
there's an easier question,
but the next one's is
quite challenging as well.
And I think a lot of parents
have this on their mind.
Vivian says one thing
that she's struggling with
is sort of that she's struggling with
is that both parents
are working full time.
They've got meetings on
Zoom at the same time.
And so the gist of the question is like,
how should they think about screen child,
screen time for their child,
especially when they are on Zoom calls
two, three hours a day.
What's the best way to think about it
and the best way to control
the amount of screen time
that they're exposing?
- Yeah, I think,
we're very cognizant of the
American Academy of Pediatrics,
who guidelines around screen time,
and have designed our app to fit
within those constraints
on recommendations.
But I'd also say,
especially during this time,
when we're all really
challenged and stressed,
give yourself some forgiveness
and grace in this area.
And I may not look so
much at the screen time.
I mean, you're talking about
two to three hours a day,
so it's not like excessive,
but look at the quality
of the screen time,
what is the screen time
bringing to your child?
And how is your child
engaging in that time?
So it's there's a huge
array of options, obviously,
and from very passive experiences
where the child you can just
see them get glazed over.
And also things that are not
developmentally appropriate
where you're just gonna be
overstimulated or not learning.
But if they're using time,
screen time in a constructive way,
so if it's a Zoom call with their teacher,
and their teacher is
having them sing or dance
or do activities,
and they're also getting
some social interaction
with their peers, that's
very active screen time,
or if they're learning
particular skills on a program
that's been designed by educators
and has learning goals at the forefront.
And it's really about
active minds on learning,
which you'll be able to see
as you observe your child's
learning the screen time,
and that's those are healthy ways
to be engaging in screen time.
And I think,
very good options for when you cannot be
in front of your child 100% of the time,
but it does sound like you
are trying to curb the time
and I'd say also extending,
if your child's really
interested in a certain app
or something like that,
maybe asking them to
take it offline and draw
and tell a story about that character
or something like that.
Renee I don't know if you want to jump in.
- Yeah, I think, I would one thing.
This may be something parents
are already doing or aware of,
but do try and have your
kiddo be somewhat near you
when they're on screen time.
So give them some headphones.
So it's not disruptive
to what you're doing.
But if it's possible, again,
I recognize sometimes it's
not possible and that's okay.
But it is, that way,
you can kind of keep an eye on
just what they're what it is
that they're doing.
Especially in the case
that you have a kiddo
who maybe can switch
screens or switch apps
without you realizing it.
And then yes, exactly.
Like Caroline said, you always wanna have
something ready for your kiddo to go
if they want to transition off screens
or you want to try and encourage them
to transition off screen so
having something out a puzzle
that's about that is partway
started, a Lego activity
that's partway started, a paint
like the paint's ready to go
so they can just get going on it.
That kind of thing.
At least that way when they look up,
there's something else that
they can go to immediately
and might be interesting to them.
That's a tough one for sure.
- So I think we have time
for one more question.
And Renee perhaps you
could start with this one
and Caroline if you have anything to add.
Hilary asks, my five
year old doesn't choose
the choices I give her.
She says no, and that
she wants something else.
Even if I tell her she
can't have something else.
Any inspiring ideas that you have there.
- Right, so this might be a good time
to ask your child ahead of time,
what are some choices that
you would like to have?
So, without making the,
without promising that
she'll get to have them say, hey,
I wanted some new ideas for choices
that you might like to
do or like to play with.
That might help with just
coming up with new ideas.
The other thing to keep
in mind and be aware of
is it could be that she
wants something else entirely
like to spend time with you.
And so that might
require a little bit more
of a conversation and just checking in
maybe a few extra times during the day.
So letting her know when
you're gonna check in with her
and making sure to honor that time,
so she knows when it's coming.
So you might say, these
are your choices for now.
I will be back in 15 minutes,
and I wanna hear all about
what you've been working on.
Or then we can read a story.
Or then we can watch a show together,
whatever is something
that she feels comfortable
doing with you, could be more
than that she wants that time.
I have to say my preteen
who's 11 right now
has suddenly become really demanding
about breakfast every day,
which she's been making herself breakfast
for a really long time and I really think
it's her attach point for me,
she wants to get up and she
wants to be able to be near me
while she's eating breakfast.
So even our older kids, I
think are looking for that.
So keep that in mind,
that may be something
happening with your little one as well.
- Any other advice, Caroline or.
- No, I just had a quick thought of like,
building on Renee's idea
of having the child come
up with a few choices,
then maybe you put them all into a box,
and then next time, you can pick one
and maybe that element of
surprise would add some intrigue
to the option.
- That's a great idea,
that's a great idea.
And similarly sometimes you
can rotate like a bucket,
a few toy choices in and out.
So, today these are your toy choices.
But tomorrow we'll have these toy choices.
Kind of put the other ones away
so she can't see them or access them.
So she is constantly changing up
and it looks a little bit
different all the time.
- Right, well, unfortunate
that's about all the time we have
for the questions.
And so Caroline I wanna
thank you and Renee
for sharing your expertise
with our audience.
And as you can see, thank you
the audience for submitting
such great questions.
And taking the time out
of your busy schedules
to be with us,
we really appreciate that.
As I mentioned before, if you
miss anything, don't worry,
we've recorded this entire session.
And we'll be posting that available online
shortly after this webinar.
And in fact, when you register,
you'll automatically be getting this email
with the links to the recording.
And then if you need more resources,
or you wanna learn more,
you can always go to khankids.org,
which is our website
for Khan Academy Kids.
And there, there's a
blue banner at the top
that links to our distance
learning resources as well.
And we update those
things all of the time.
So, please come by and
check out, check by often.
And then before we sign off,
we wanna ask you to do us one favor.
There's a poll that pops up at
the very end of this webinar
and ask two important questions.
The first is help us
make future iterations
of this session even better.
So if you have any
questions or suggestions,
please put that there.
And then secondly,
we're always looking to create
more content to help you.
So if the, if you have
any subjects or topics
that you would like us to dig in deeper,
please add your suggestions there as well.
So, from all of us at Khan Academy Kids,
we just wanna thank you again and goodbye.